[Music]
a study out this week finds that the
drought which dried up parts of Europe
China and the U.S over the summer was
made 20 times more likely by climate
change the drought had a particularly
hard impact on California which leads
all states in agricultural output that's
LED some Farmers there to consider a
different crop which requires much less
water Elizabeth Kling from our
Sacramento station kovr has the story
from Yolo County California
on a dry Dusty Hill in Yolo County
nestled between rows of olives and
almonds a strange and spiky sight
Craig Reynolds started them as an
experiment and now the Secret's out it's
kind of almost too much to handle right
now it's uh I get phone calls every day
from all over the place saying how where
can I get some Agave seedlings
grown in Mexico when used for making
tequila is now proving to be an ideal
crop for California's water-strapped
fields
we're growing Agave here with one tenth
or less the water that we were using to
grow olives that were previous in this
field and once established the plants
can keep growing with almost no water at
all there's just one catch growing Agave
takes some time it'll be at least six
years before these new plants are ready
for Harvest then it's a matter of
getting to the heart of the plant which
takes a special tool called akoa and
some special skills
Raul Sanders learned to harvest Agave as
a kid in Mexico
[Music]
and he's now putting his expertise to
work here as a humidor
close to the close to the Pina
here you go like this there you go
I think a lot of
yagave and they
and they that you're after but it's not
no it's not it's only the Pina the Pina
is weighing 100 pounds or more a piece
are then collected and sold to local
distilleries eager to get in on an
Emerging Market the whole idea of The
Distillery always enticed me Patricia
wise owns Nick's Taco Mexican Kitchen
and Distillery the first question is are
you going to make your own tequila I'm
like well I'm going to make agave
Spirits I can't say that I'm going to be
making tequila or Mezcal for that matter
in California we can't call it tequila
or Mezcal we call it Agave Spirits just
like champagne we call it sparkling wine
what you call it doesn't matter it's
what's in the bottle that matters and
what's in these bottles is pretty good
what's in these bottles is fantastic and
people are willing to pay a good price
for it making California grown agave and
their distilled Spirits a refreshing
option amidst concerns of an even drier
future we've basically proved the
concept that you can grow agave in
California and make wonderful Spirits
now several thousand acres of agave are
in the planning stages across the state
offering Farmers weary for water A
Renewed sense of spirit for CBS Saturday
morning Elizabeth clang Yolo County
California
so I wonder if managave Moves In what
will happen to Wine Country considering
you know well wine country doesn't go
anywhere people drinking tequila they're
having some problems I mean the heat the
record heat has been really tough yeah
no but I think it's a great way yeah to
use that land and be able to find
special one-tenth of the water that they
use in olives